why am i single why hey guys it's Alex
so as many of you know I'm single and
lately a lot of people have been asking
me how to cook if you're single now not
to brag but I've been single my entire
life so I know a thing or two about
cooking for one I thought I'd just share
some advice on how I do it with three
awesome recipes for breakfast lunch and
dinner for one I'm single and ready to
mingle with some food alright starting
with the most important meal of the day
breakfast I love eggs because eggs
aren't cheap they're a good source of
protein and there's so much you can do
with them last week I actually had this
crazy dream where I dreamt of a crispy
cheese omelet when I woke up in the
morning I was like I've got to see if
this works and I tried it and let me
tell you it has changed the omelet game
for me from here on out always follow
your dreams so I'm just gonna start by
cracking my eggs in a bowl scramble them
up and I'm gonna season them with salt
and pepper it's a great option if you
have a busy schedule and need a quick
breakfast for one and what's also great
is that eggs each come in one egg all
the eggs are single too they get me this
is why I'm single by the way this is the
khaki fly okay moving on to the stove I
have a nonstick pan over medium heat I'm
gonna spray down the pan with a little
cooking spray this will help make sure
the cheese doesn't stick to the pan
later on put some cheese right on the
pan I'm using Parmesan cheese because
it's a harder cheese and it will crisp
up really nicely this is about like a
half a cup I'd say so the cheese is
melting down and getting really bubbly
what we're looking for is for the edges
to start to get a little brown and
crispy before you put the eggs on you
don't want to go too far because you
want to ensure there's enough time for
the eggs to cook before the cheese burns
so now I'm gonna go ahead and pour my
eggs right on top of the cheese it
should completely cover the circle of
cheese that we just made it's the circle
the circle of tea
you know what my future husband is lucky
I'll tell you bad so now I'm gonna
reduce the heat to low and cover the
eggs with a lid so that they have a
chance to cook on top you could also
fill this omelet with some veggies or
some bacon or some extra cheese if you
want to go wild so now that my egg is
cooked on top I'm gonna take the lid off
and just flip it on over itself oh my
gosh look at that crispy cheese on the
outside all right see how easy that was
a quick and delicious breakfast let's
try it hmm you up egg that salty bite
and then that crispy cheese it's so good
all right so that's breakfast I will see
you around lunch time for lunch
I love to meal prep meal prepping is
great because it saves you time it saves
you money and things don't go to waste
I'm gonna be making some delicious
turkey taco bowls I'm gonna add some
olive oil to the pan some sliced red and
green peppers and some sliced red onion
season that with some salt and pepper
and we're gonna just start cooking these
down until they get nice and soft all
right my vegetables are looking nice and
soft I am just gonna go ahead and remove
them from the pan so we're setting our
vegetables aside for now to the same pan
I'm adding a little more oil and my
ground turkey you can really use any
kind of meat you want here you can use
ground beef you could use ground chicken
or you could totally skip the meat and
just do the black beans and veggies so
now I'm gonna season my turkey with a
little salt some ground cumin some
paprika and some chili powder and just
start to break down the meat I know
we're cooking a few components here but
it is super simple it'll last you the
whole week and it's easy to reheat so my
turkey is cooked I'm gonna add in a cup
of salsa and a cup of water so now I'm
gonna reduce the heat and bring this to
a low simmer so that we can cook off
some of that liquid it's a little bit
saucy it's a little bit spicy
like my love life alright our meat is
done and now we're gonna put the bowls
together I am starting with some rice at
the bottom of my Tupperware you can use
any kind of rice you want next I'm gonna
add some of our taco meat right into the
Tupperware our sautéed veggies this
actually makes like for full meals now I
have some corn some black beans and now
I like to add a little bit of cheddar
cheese when you microwave it it will
melt down and be really delicious
a lime wedge and each and a little
cilantro before I put these away of
course I got to try it it's lunchtime
I'm hungry mmm really good there's so
much variety there's lots of colors and
it packs a ton of flavor and then you're
set for a week how cool is that
if only dating were this easy alright
I'm gonna finish my lunch and then I'll
see you around dinner time for our
little dates all right for the grand
finale it's dinner time now I feel like
people have an idea that single people
just get a lot of delivery but there is
no reason you can't make yourself a
delicious homemade dinner for one so I'm
gonna show you my favorite recipe for an
easy chicken piccata
so for chicken piccata we're gonna need
a boneless skinless chicken breast I'm
just gonna butterfly this chicken breast
by cutting it in half so I'm going to
cover it with some parchment and use a
heavy bottomed pan to pound it out you
can also take out some of your
aggressions during this time why am i
single and then I'm just gonna cut it
into two pieces a season both sides with
salt and pepper so now that our chicken
is powder thin and seasoned I am gonna
coat it in some flour I love cooking
dinner I think it's my favorite meal of
the day you can listen to some music
a little wine so get that all nice and
coated and then shake off any excess
flour all right our chicken is ready
moving on over to the stove alright so
starting with a non-stick pan over a
medium heat I'm gonna add a couple
tablespoons of olive oil and a couple
tablespoons of butter we're gonna melt
that down completely before we add in
our chicken you don't have to use the
combo of oil and butter here but I like
it because it gives you that extra
buttery richness alright our butter is
melted and our oil is hot I'm gonna add
in the chicken I always like to lay it
away from me just to make sure I don't
get splashed without oil so now we're
gonna cook the chicken until golden
brown and cook through but actually
shouldn't take that long just a few
minutes on each side but make sure it's
all the way cooked 300 to 165 degrees
okay our chicken is cooked I'm gonna
take it out of the pan I'm gonna deglaze
the pan with a little chicken stock and
a little white wine you want to use a
dry white wine here what's also great
about cooking with wine is that you can
drink it so now I'm just gonna give this
sauce a stir this will be really
delicious in the sauce for flavor I also
turn down the heat to a medium low and
reduce the sauce so it gets a little bit
thicker and while my sauce is cooking
I'm gonna heat up a pot of water for the
spaghetti I also like to multitask in
the kitchen because the sooner you get
it done the sooner you get to eat I'm
gonna add in 3 tablespoons of capers I'm
also gonna add the juice of half of a
lemon and finally I'm gonna add a couple
more tablespoons of butter so generally
for pasta for one I just use like a
handful like that you can use as much
pasta as you want there's no one judging
you all right we've got all of our
components we've got our pasta we've got
our chicken we've brought our sauce it's
time to plate and eat this thing so
first I'm gonna put down our spaghetti
you can do it a whole fancy you know
like they do in restaurants presentation
counts just like they say you should get
dressed every day you should make your
meals look nice every day just cuz no
one else sees it doesn't mean that you
can't make it look nice and right on top
goes our chicken and then
right on over top of our chicken goes
our beautiful pan sauce I like to put
some on the pasta as well and the best
part is this recipe made enough for two
meals so you can eat a nice dinner
tonight and save the rest for tomorrow
now I'm gonna pour myself a little glass
of one again we don't waste anything
here you know the other great part about
being single you don't have to share
it's just the perfect dish
well salty from the capers you've got
the acid from the lemon and then the
richness from the sauce well there you
go three easy delicious meals to make
for breakfast lunch and dinner if you're
a single I hope this gave you some
inspiration if you're not single I still
recommend these dishes if you do make
them be sure to tag me on Instagram I'd
love to see your work as for me I'm
gonna swipe right on out of here see you
later
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]